peu
[Musique]
ça lui offrant un évidemment ça ne
pouvait être que vous que tu me
présenter à la chaux pour tel isabelle
de carantec
mais vous n'êtes pas si cela n'empêche
pas l'autre venait il s'appelle vous
allez prendre froid
bertrand genève ots l'antivol parce
qu'ici c'est plus prudent et je vous
rejoins tout de suite on se dit vraiment
impossible de vaccination etienne obligé
vous avez entendu son nom de matinée
j'ai fait attention
chauveau pour dit elle les concerts elle
même et quand je faisais part il ya des
francs soit ou si vous connaissez des
choses dont on est mieux patienter
je pensais que vous le saviez comme on
investit dans toutes les interviews
qu'il accorde à la presse ils n'arrêtent
pas parler sa famille pour dire du mal
bien sûr l'autre jour encore il y avait
un grand article où il racontait comment
son père l'avait mis à la porte en
apprenant qu'il voulait faire l'artiste
et comment maintenant ce même terre aux
frais des disques assez d'employés pour
les étrennes
v non ici nous connaissons qu'alain
choghour tél c'est bien en tant que tels
que nous avons dû l'admettre
l'association jade et les certificats
moeurs en règle oui et j'en étais bien
éplucher et comme nous n'y avons pas
trouvé le moindre vice de forme il a
fallu l'acceptent
en fait bertrand gille ma poudre et vous
rient jamais vraiment mais sinon ça n'a
pas d'importance une amie vos empreintes
marché de l'allergie je ne peux dire que
les miens bertand je suis heureux de
vous rencontrer
j'ai appelé votre bureau cet après-midi
excusez-moi père tranché ac jusqu'à
l'annoncé vous accompagner mais c'est
pas la peine de rester avec votre ami
chalet pour illuminer mais coûteux
[Musique]
vous partez déjà non même chercher
si je vais dd oui je vous répondrais que
je vous appelle à l'aide matérielle
comme lui que vous vous pouviez pas
m'atteindre vous ne saviez pas que
j'allais revenir je n'avais aucune
raison de revenir à plus que je n'avais
de raison de vous avant et pourtant vous
êtes revenu et pourtant je vous attendu
mais pourquoi mais parce que nous
croyons au conte de fées ça n'existe
plus les contes de fées vous sur nos
pieds fait peur je connaissais un très
joli d'horribles dragons peu au jeu ne
me souviens pas de tous je crois que
n'ai jamais su l'efs
je connais peut-être aussi je vous
aiderai commencer il était une fois dans
une grande maison très luxueuse et très
triste
une jeune fille qui s'appelait isabelle
âge était très douce très jeune
[Musique]